comment on a commencé ce court métrage
est pendant deux ans que tu m'as fait du
lobbying pour jaye au japon qui m'a dit
au japon où vas tu vas tu vas kiffer j'y
suis allé j'ai kiffé appels provenant de
fait peut-être fait le japon est déjà un
projet au japon gérez vous gêne un peu
travaillé au corps vous savez je vais
enfin du japon je voulais un projet où
je me dis je reste plus longtemps et
surtout j'échange avec les gens avec un
projet comme vrai je me suis dit un
tournage ça paraît évident à peine
arrivé on a commencé les repérages
est ce qu on avait tous les yeux par
photo en fait les décors qui était très
très importante c'était la maison de
minorer ce c'est là où se passe la
résolution est aussi l'éditeur parce que
c'est là où ça fait figure officiel
c'est le rêve de adrien donc du coup il
nous fallait des endroits très précis
quand on parlait du tournage ap andy
warhol une semaine un début un peu calme
on pourra peut-être allé au studio
ghibli machin et ses enfants on a repéré
le premier jour le deuxième jour en
tournée c'était très important pour nous
d'avoir un casting japonais oui pour le
rôle de tommy nouri le père de minori
l'éditeur est donc un casting heures à
tokyo dès qu'on a reçu les auditions
là c'est vraiment j'ai l'impression de
lire à voix mais le film et va exister
c'est sur ces trois fois qu'on entend
des deux textes du scénario en japonais
joué par des japonais
une année on a regardé les auditions et
des comme ça va s'y passe à la suivante
je me voir parce qu'il faut le rôle
important c'était le rôle de bieber y
est on a trouvé mia rue elle est elle
même un peu minorés l'aumônerie timide
gentil volontaire
tu termines at inc
[Musique]
on vient de faire la première lecture
lapointe fois qu'on entend vraiment les
répliques dit par toi et par les
comédiens potache thaçi thimoté je dois
diriger en anglais quelqu'un qui doit
abolir le texte en japonais cyprien le
jeu parlant français
il lui delà des chiffres et en japonais
et avoir la tentation avant la silice
j'ai tous à apprendre en japonais du jeu
parce que j'emporterais kim acheta
watashi nos mangas cadets et louise est
en train de se [ __ ] de ma gueule
derrière robinho pas louise ben oui ce
bien sûr philippe d'assemblage pied une
équipe franco japonaise pour la fiction
à tokyo c'était parfait poindre la scène
dans les bacs à y ajouter une des
premières scènes de dialogues qu'on a
tourné ces pays avec tous les acteurs
japonais
aucun parler anglais vraiment là les
figurants franchement l'ordonné très
très peu d'indications
oui il va parler un peu en français un
peu pour lui-même il est bourré et dès
qu'ils entendent un bon français disent
aime bien tout le monde peut le répéter
et du coup on était vraiment en train de
dire ok on insiste on sait pas ce qui se
passe bcc on est à chercher la chanson
culte on ne connaît en français c'est
aux champs elysées ya connaissent
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est fou parce que t'es trop cyprien
est plus dans le plan on est vraiment
dans le film de gangsters avec les
séries mal et tout cela mais je tape
c'est un peu mon rêve se réalise si on a
tourné la manger là bah oui c'est super
on
[Applaudissements]
mais quatre jours qu'ont fait les
premières journées et ça c'était
vraiment une journée
vivaldi de myope sont là bas on est
petit geste pour me dire action je vois
rien ok c'est super d'avoir enfin
beaucoup de dialogues blue comédie
beaucoup d'émotion puis dans un décor et
qui talent fou la décoratrice qui a fait
la petite chambre de minorer n'y a rien
dedans la base un c'est ça c'était des
tatamis c'est évident
salut qu on arrive enfin comprendre
kiminori juste quelques décors elle est
dessinatrice mais elle n'est pas non
plus trop kawaii il fallait trouver les
bonnes rech et elle nous l'a recouvert
la chambre de détail à la mine de riz
avec des vrais croquis mais deux teams
fischer ça marche trop bien c'est les
bonnes couleurs sessegnon s'est chargé
en même temps c'est top mais elles n'ont
que brièvement échappé truc
elle rejoint elle se met à côté de lui
c'est comme ça vraiment on a un vrai
cadre on voit vraiment ça maintenant on
a des cours c'était beaucoup plus clair
et on s'en sert à gratter je crois que
ça manquait de dab
[Musique]
quand je le vois avec une gaffe en train
de diriger les gens je n'ai vu comment
il faut concours youtube
si j'y vais c'est du jazz français voilà
aucun sens tony ses toiles ont préféré
se faire du vélo c'est génial énorme
satisfaction de faire du vélo à tokyo
devait te forcer à dire à mater en
galère l'a totalement en mode pourtant
d'être haletant curbelo jeunes on met
l'accent cette fille tellement beau et
qu'à ses résidents fleurs et truc c'est
compliqué d'avoir un vélo taille
japonaise et d'avoir quelqu'un dans son
dos la pochette faille tout un truc ça
tombe bien on est bon on va trouver je
pense symbolique
les dessins entre vous qui vous relie si
vous colle comme le fromage dans un
burger
si on va l'entendre le scandinave a vu
partir un mode tokyo drift voir
ja rule me guide c'est mon gps
[Musique]
chauffer en hiver également les
personnages adrien essaie de retrouver
minori avec ses planches à elle et ses
planches comporte beaucoup de décors
dont qui se dit peut-être si je vais
revisiter ses décors là je vais la
trouver donc du coup il ya cette petite
astuce où on voit la case et on découvre
ensuite le vrai décor et du coup cela le
conforte
et pour arriver à ça comment ça se passe
moi je fais un repérage sur google
street view mais vraiment je me pomme
avec mon petit bonhomme je le déplace
jockey j'aime bien cet escalier
une fois que j'ai trouvé ça j'en vois la
preuve regardez ces lieux-là meguro au
japon se déplacent ils prennent les
photos à des photos dans différents
angles - surtout le choc je fais d'une
fausse planches ne s'est pas encore
dessiné je revois le fichier intime
fisher qu'il ya des sénateurs plus bas
avec ces photos il a redessiné à
l'identique
il a rajouté les personnages à
l'intérieur ça a été imprimé et voilà
c'est aussi bête et au final moi je suis
très satisfait du nul moi ce que je
redoutais le plus c'était les tournages
dans la rue dans les dieux où il ya
littéralement le nombre de gens m'ont km
carrés on a envie d'essayer en vain car
les traversées or et c'est là haut ou
alors on va le perdre
c'est ainsi qu'en
d'accord on a tourné dans l'endroit le
plus chaud de tokyo à l'heure où les
gens étaient le plus ça va dire fêtards
et u23 peuples ont fait beaucoup de
caméras et loup il disait je suis désolé
les gens sont un peu bourré j'ai
franchement ils sont très durs très très
calme quand on filme dans la rue dans le
métro etc
en fait il ya une telle civilité oui que
tout le monde se respecte
oui il ya un tournage on va pas les
déranger ça s'est très très bien passé
et on a fait je pense des images que
j'adore apparemment le métro en toute
chose c'est hyper iconique en fait c'est
le transport le plus ou moins quitte à
dire des millions de personnes du coup
fait honneur on a beaucoup discuté de
notre expérience tout français au japon
mais c'est ça qu'on a essayé de mettre
dans le scénar c'était 2-0 qu'est y
avait l'histoire de base qui est
vraiment un passionné de manga français
qui veulent percer au japon et aussi
cette particularité qui est que quand tu
es français au japon
tu es mal élevés sans faire exprès de
balle de vastes et français des français
donc tu es mal élevés pour eux c'est le
père noël et du coup je trouvais ça
rigolo qu'on puisse jouer là dessus sur
ces différences de culture sur un mec
qui veut pas déranger pour autant métier
fait un peu tout à côté
grâce aux éditions kana j'ai pu parler
du métier de mangaka avec inio asano
auteur entre autres de bonnie ping-pong
et solanin ainsi qu'avec conoco ce
qu'est hauteur de la voie du tablier je
leur ai demandé s'il pensait possible
pour un français de devenir mangaka au
japon comme le désir adrien dans le
court métrage pour fighting noir sarko
va
merci beaucoup d'être tellement d'années
car elle a été rénovée mini nippon des
technocrates et les autunois les kings
et maïs on avait tous avec aussi à
l'équipe image en cas de charlotte et
arthur envie de capturer le maximum
l'image de tokyo
du coup quand je repense à tous ces
jours là je me dis mais en fait c'était
comme un tournage continue c'est ça on
vivait vraiment le court métrage
pratiques n'ont été prouvé dans des
oeufs au plat et pour moi dans ce projet
là j'ai essayé de mettre des petits
objectif essayer de montrer le japon
collaborer avec des japonais est aussi
créé un petit voyage avec plein de
souvenirs
on était une petite équipe de sept
français tout les cas sont cochés pont
c'était très familial ques agca g t au
delà de mes espérances quoi moi
personnellement je n'arrive de voyager
ça arrive d'être un touriste mais je le
vis très mal d'être juste un touriste
est là le fait de se dire ok on est plus
les touriste on participe vraiment à
cette vie là on travaille un peu on a
une vision différente c'était ça qui
était plaisant c'était ok ça rien à voir
avec juste le fait d'être là prendre des
photos on vivait le tout de l'intérieur
avec des vrais gens
[Musique]
sacré
toi
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner oui voilà
bien sûr à sa chaîne certaines chaînes
juste un futur abonnez vous
[Musique]